so
me a developer machine learning
researcher how do i lex freeman
participate in this competition
and how do others i'm sure there'll be a
lot of others interested in
participating in this competition
what are let's see there's like a
million questions but like first one
is how do i get started well
you can go to numer.ai sign up
download the data and on
the data is pretty small um in the data
pack you download
there's like an example script python
script that just builds
a xg boost model very quickly from the
data
and um so in a very short time you can
have an example
model is it a particular structure like
what uh
is this model then submitted somewhere
so there's needs to be some kind of
structure that communicates with some
kind of api
like how does the whole yeah how does
the your model once you build it wants
to create a little
little baby frankenstein how does it
then live in it's okay well we want you
to keep your baby frankenstein at home
and take care of it we don't want it
okay so we you never upload
your model to us you always um
only giving us predictions so we never
see the code that wrote your model which
is pretty cool yeah that our whole hedge
fund is built from
models where we've never ever seen the
code um
but it's important for the users because
it's their ip
why do they want to give it to us that's
brilliant so they've got it
themselves but they can basically almost
like license
the the predictions from that
so think about it what some users do is
they set up a
compute server we call numeric compute
it's like a little aws kind of image
and you can automate this process um so
we can ping you we can be like we need
more predictions now
and then you you send it to us okay cool
so that that's
uh is that described somewhere like what
the preferred is the aws
or whether another cloud platform is
there
i mean is there sort of specific
technical things you want to say
that comes to mind that uh is a good
path
for getting started so download the data
maybe play around
see if you can modify the basic
uh the algorithm provided in
the example and then you
what set up a little server on the aws
that then
runs this model and takes pings and then
makes predictions
and uh how does your own money actually
come into play
during the stake of um cryptocurrency
yeah so you don't have to stake you can
start without staking and many users
might
try for months without staking anything
at all to see if their model
works on the real life data right and is
not over
fit but then you can get numeraire
many different ways you can buy it on um
you can buy some on coinbase you can buy
some on
uniswap you can buy some on binance um
so what did you say this is uh how do
you pronounce it so this is the numerai
uh cryptocurrency yeah nmr
nmr what's you just say nmr it is
it is technically called numero numero
i like it yeah but uh and more simple
nmr numero okay so and you could buy it
uh you know basically anywhere yeah so
it's a bit strange because sometimes
people were like
is this like pay to play right and it's
like
sword it's like yeah yeah you need to
put some money down
to show us you believe in your model
right but uh weirdly we
we're not selling you the cr like you
can't buy the cryptocurrency from
us right it's like it's also
we never if you're if you do badly
um we destroy your cryptocurrency
okay that's not good right you don't
want it to be destroyed but
what's good about it is it's also not
coming to us
right so it's not like we win when you
lose or something like that like we're
the house
like we're definitely on the same team
yes you're helping us make a hedge fund
that's never been done before
yeah so again interests are aligned
there's no uh there's no tension there
at all which is
which is really fascinating you're
giving away everything and then the ip
is owned by
sort of the code you never share the
code that's fascinating
um so since i have you here and you said
hundredth i didn't ask out of how many
so we'll just
but if i if i then once you get started
and you find this
interesting how do you then
win or do well but also how do you
potentially try to win if this is
something you want to take on seriously
from the machine learning perspective
not from a financial perspective
yeah i think um there first of all you
want to talk to the community people are
pretty open
uh we give out really interesting
scripts and ideas
for things you might want to try um and
uh but you're also going to need a lot
of compute probably
and so some of the best users are are
you know actually the very first time
someone won
on numerix i would i wrote them a
personal emails like that you know
you've won some money
we're so excited to give you three
hundred dollars and then they said i
spend way more on the compute
[Laughter]
um but this is fundamentally a machine
learning problem first i think
is this is one of the exciting things i
don't know if we'll in
how many ways we can approach this but
really this is
less about kind of
no offense but like finance people
finance minded people they're
also i'm sure great people but it feels
like from the community that i've
experienced
these are people who see finance as a
fascinating uh problem space
the source of data but ultimately
they're machine learning people or ai
people
which is a very different kind of flavor
of community and i mean
i should say to that uh i'd love to
participate in this and
i will participate in this and i'd love
to hear from other people if you're
listening to this if you're a machine
learning person
you should participate and tell me uh
give me some hints
um how i can uh do well at this thing
because this boomer
uh i'm not sure i still got it but
because some of it is uh it's like
kaggle competitions like
some of it is certainly a set of ideas
like research ideas
and like fundamental innovation but i'm
sure some of it is like deeply
understanding getting like an
intuition about the data and then like a
lot of it will be like figuring out like
what works like tricks
i mean you could argue most of deep
learning research is just tricks on top
of tricks but
there is uh some of it is just the art
of getting to know how to work in a
really difficult machine learning
problem
and i think what's important the
important difference with something like
a kaggle competition
where they'll set up this kind of toy
problem
and then there will be an out of sample
test like hey you did well out of sample
and this is like okay
cool um but what's cool with nimrod is
you're you're the out of sample is the
real live stock market
we we don't even know like we don't know
the answer to the problem
we don't like you'll have to find out
live and so we've had
users who've like submitted every week
for for like
four years um because
it's kind of a interest we say it's the
hardest
data science problem on the planet right
and it sounds maybe sounds like
maybe a bit too much like a marketing
thing but it's
the hardest because it's the stock
market it's like literally they're like
billions of dollars at stake and like no
one's like
letting it be inefficient on purpose so
if you can find something that works on
numerai you really have something that
that is like working on the real stock
market
yeah because there's like humans
involved in the stock market i mean
that's
uh you know you could argue there might
be harder data sets like maybe
predicting the weather all those kinds
of things but
the the fundamental statement here is
which i like i was thinking like is this
really the hardest data science problem
and you start thinking about that but
ultimately also boils down to
a problem where the data is accessible
it's made accessible made
really easy and efficient at
like submitting algorithms so it's not
just
you know it's not about the data being
out there like the weather it's about
making the data super accessible
making the building a community around
it like this is what imagenet did
exactly like it's not just there's
always images
the point is you aggregate them together
you give it a little title
there's a community and that's that was
one of the hardest right for a time
and most important data science problems
in the world because it was accessible
because it was
uh made uh sort of like
there's uh mechanisms by which like
standards and mechanisms by which to
judge your performance all those kinds
of things and numerize actually
step up from that is there something
more you can say about
why from your perspective it's the
hardest uh
problem in the world i mean you said
it's connected to the market so if you
can find a pattern in the market
that's a really difficult thing to do
because a lot of people are trying to do
it
exactly but there's also the the biggest
one is
it's it's non-stationary time series
we've tried to regularize the data so
you can find
patterns by by doing certain things to
the features and the target
but ultimately you're in a space where
you don't
there's no guarantees that the
out-of-sample distributions will
uh conform to any of the training data
and and every single um
era which we call on the website like
every single era in the data which is
like
sort of showing you the order of the
time um
it's it's even the training data is has
the same
same dislocations and um so
yeah it's and so and then there's yeah
there's so many things that might um
might you might want to try this this
like there's unlimited possible number
of models right
and so
by by having it be
open we can at least search that space
you